what's going on guys this is Rob and if
you're enjoying the content that I'm
uploading on my channel and feel free to
subscribe and you can also offer
suggestions on topics and characters and
storylines and whatnot that we can have
discussions on later on in this channel
okay so spider vs. I'm not spider-verse
spider versus later
spider Island is right around the corner
and in truth the Spider Island actually
has a couple of like three weeks those
you guys who don't know whenever it
comes to crossover events whether it's
line wide which means it's like
everybody it goes through Avengers x-men
and humans the whole nine yards or if
it's just like a standalone story that
pertains to a character or a group of
people there's usually always like a
lead-in for example with Civil War -
there was the road to civil war - with
civil war 1 there was the road to Civil
War 1 they usually always have those the
road to secret invasion
there's always pre ludes that lady and I
lead into it sometimes it's just like a
whole bunch of stories for example the
lead into Dark Reign was house of an
Avengers disassembled Civil War Secret
Invasion I mean it was everything
leading up to Dark Reign there are a lot
of things going on on siege was a really
good story that tied into Dark Reign but
with regards to - Spider Island the best
prelude I think that's offered is a
story called infested and the reason why
is because what this does is it tells us
how it all starts the prologue so to
speak that is to say like amazing
spider-man number 665 I think it is it
kind of goes into it but it's not nearly
as important I don't think as the
infested story so what this does is this
picks up with Miles Warren and reason
why is because it's the most logical
person to choose when it comes to the
history of Marvel Comics and really in
the spider-man that those miles worn
really his most significant role prior
to this was Clone Saga despite the fact
that that story was heated I mean it was
panned people hated that because it was
basically Marvel introducing the notion
of replacing Peter Parker with a clone
Ben Riley but was supposed to be a story
it would basically simplify the
spider-man mythos turned out to be
anything but you go read any interview
from anybody who was part of that
project and they were like the story was
supposed to be short and before we knew
it the whole damn thing just spiraled
out of control to the point that it was
basically
insane and people hated it but miles
Warren was the guy who was behind the
cloning of Peter Parker he knew Peter
Parker's identity he basically created a
king he eventually created Ben Reilly
but so the idea was that
dance life's going to come back and it's
going to have someone give everybody in
Manhattan spider-powers
miles Warren is the most logical person
to choose now what miles Warren does is
he basically goes through and begins
adding or begins modifying the the DNA
of bedbugs with spider DNA are basically
giving people the ability to have spider
powers by way of being bitten by these
bedbugs and again that makes sense
because bedbugs are small they're not
something that you normally look for at
least if you if you basically engage in
any measure of cleanliness you don't
expect to look for a bedbug
and so because of this if they basically
just kind of pour into the city of
Manhattan now what this does is it gives
us like a series of these little two or
three issues stories will cover them all
here but it gives us an AC R is
reasonable two or three issue stories
that follow each individual person's
window granted these spider powers and
how they respond and it's actually
really really cool one of the first
people that we pick up with is a guy by
the name of Richard Davis now it's kind
of ironic here because Richard Davies is
for all intents and purposes Flash
Thompson I mean the way that his
character is portrayed here he is
basically the the jock or something like
that he's picking on the guy who was
basically the nerd it created an
interesting situation here and the
reason why Dan Slott did this is because
when it comes to the spider-man mythos
it's timeless but I mean spider-man is
timeless a kid who basically was bitten
by a radioactive spider you know he
learned that with great power comes
great responsibility that lesson was
learned at the expense of his uncle's
life you know it's a beautifully crafted
crafted story and this is the most
recognizable thank god they're not going
over that origin story again and
spider-man homecoming that was like
everybody's biggest fear they were going
to go over it again
but it's a timeless story and so to kind
of see it rehash a little bit it's
interesting even then Dan Slott says if
you ever want to see real life if you
want to see little people to really like
go to the schoolyard now this is kind of
an archaic stance that dance less taking
about it's an older ideology this was
the 1980s you know maybe even the early
1990s I'd say Dan Slott you're probably
right this is the 2000 this is the late
2000 so if you're talking about people
in their most basic form if you're
talking about people in their most
fundamental form that's the internet
when there's anonymity people don't have
to be worried don't have to worry about
being held accountable for the things
they say and do and so it's people in
their most basic form but the idea here
is that this kid there's a particular
person that's being picked on Richard
Davies basically you know gains these
spider powers by way of a bite from one
of these bedbugs and then his spider
sense goes off when he realizes that the
guy he's picking on has a gun and he
tends to shoot Richard Davies now of
course Richard Davis is able to counter
he uses a super strength and he attacks
this guy and kills him in the process
and this is really really cool because
what this is is Dan Slott drawing on the
lessons learned from ultimate spider-man
remember in the first arc which comic
story is coming right now you know what
in the very beginning of ultimate
spider-man one of the first lessons
Peter Parker had to learn was that
Dermer that he basically has to pull his
punches that if he didn't pull his
punches he would kill people and so
because of that he basically had to come
to this realization that he can't just
go full in when it comes to fighting
various supervillains that he has to
fight supervillains with with you know
being cognitive cognizant of what he's
capable of Richard Davies wasn't raised
with that lesson he wasn't taught how to
use those powers it's just suddenly he
has the spider sense he just kind of
snaps into action he reflexes and he
kills this kid in the process and the
responses that Richard Davies it's
basically on the run he's a fugitive
hiding from the police and he's wanted
for murder now at this point we switch
over to another guy and the person that
we join is Walter Coleman now watcher
Walter Coleman is kind of like this
predecessor to renew your vows that was
really interesting thing here because
remember in the world of comics
everything is happened before and it'll
all happen again it's basically the same
thing stories just get recycled every
story that can be told has been told
there's a reason why we're seeing
Superman with a son for the first time
now because in a 70 some-odd year
history we've never seen that before
it's new it's fresh but after a while
that story will have been told where do
you go from there so what we do here is
with Walter Coleman he takes us kind of
renew your vows stamps the reason why I
say that is because during the events of
secret Wars Marvel released the story
you know spider-man renew your vows and
what it was was kind of like this this
throwback to fans who really wanted to
see Peter Parker and Mary Jane Watson
get back together and they wanted to see
how that life would function with renew
your vows it was basically Peter Parker
walking away from being a superhero a
new villain named the region had shown
up on the scene he was basically
kidnapping superheroes he was using them
keeping them prisoner in the process and
the result was that during this massive
battle between what was left to be
Avengers and and Regent himself Peter
Parker had to choose between Mary Jane
and his family or fighting alongside the
Avengers he chose Mary Jane he left the
Avengers behind and he basically had to
hide he had to basically pretend that he
wasn't a superhero his family had to
follow the exact same pattern this very
much takes the same approach and we get
these really cool juxtaposition between
characters between super I'm sorry
between us spider-man and between Walter
Coleman where spider-man is
basically saving people from burning
buildings so on and so forth Walter
Coleman is basically had to watch his
neighbors burn to death and the reason
why is because he said look I got these
powers I have these abilities yes I
could have saved their lives
but I'm a family man I've got a family
to protect you know I'm sorry about
their luck that's their problem you know
I take care of my family first and that
makes sense you know I mean if you're a
person and your family struggling
financially you know and your kids are
hungry you don't fix a sandwich for the
family across the street you fix a
sandwich for your kids you keep your
house in order you take care of your
house and then you worry about those
guys across the street and if they'll
make it that's their problem not yours
and so the whole idea here is that it
gives us really really cool situation it
gives us very real world how people
should normally function type of
situation and it comes out kind of cool
but in the end it's just another
instance where a person just uses their
powers it really doesn't use their
powers and takes it in a completely
different direction but at this point we
switch over to a guy named Mattie Oh
cauldron I think it's how you pronounce
his last name but again this is the guy
who basically is just you know supplying
drugs he's basically a drug dealer
that's really it you know just a drug
runner here and he's funny a fighting
cloak-and-dagger there's no real huge
story here it's basically just a
cloak-and-dagger are beginning to
realize that people are popping up on
the scene that have the powers of
spider-man and it creates a really
interesting situation because for then
they don't quite know how to handle this
remember when it comes to Peter Parker
facing off against him is a very
dangerous situation because Ellie right
now he doesn't have a spider sense of
course we saw that but spider-man big
time he lost his spider sense but for
those individuals that do have it the
spider senses were cute spider-man on
top if you take spider-man's
spider-sense away well then he's just
got the same powers everybody okay he's
got super strength to received
durability and they can crawl on walls
which is kind of cool you can shoot
webbing lanessa it I mean you know
without a spider simply can't be alerted
danger so all it would take is the
Punisher sitting on top of a roof 100
yards away and Peter Parker's not with
us anymore
that's not really safe I mean we saw
that during original sin right you know
during the whole original sin story when
Nick Fury was established as being a man
on the wall where he was basically
taking care of threat within the earth
and beyond the earth when Peter Parker
first popped up Nick Fury was going to
kill him in that time period between
when Peter Parker first became
spider-man before his fighters since
fully developed and he began to
understand how it works
Nick Fury came across him was sitting on
a rooftop took aim and plan to kill him
but the Nick Fury said well no I think
this is a good guy and Peter Parker live
it was one of those really cool retcons
where it was like you know Peter Parker
was a bullet well I'm sorry what was a
Birger pull away from being killed and
so it was a really cool situation but
again from here we switch over to two
shang-chi there we go and shea cheese
basically like Bruce Lee in the Marvel
Universe I mean I have a hard time
finding anybody who would refute that
claim that's basically what he is it's
cool
I love Schanke he's a really cool
character but he's basically Bruce Lee
in the in the Marvel Universe but the
issue here is that remember because
Peter Parker doesn't have a spider since
he has to essentially rely on other
memes to begin getting around his guys
the way he normally would because it
would with Peter Parker I wouldn't say
his spider sense was a crutch so much as
I would say his spider sense was an
intrinsic part of who he was you know it
was an arm it was a leg it was a it was
a foot you know it was it was a fist it
was very much an intrinsic part of what
his character was he relied on his
spider sense as much as he relied on his
agility his wedding all that kind of
good stuff to have it taken away means
that now he has to be able to compensate
and this is cool because what he does if
he develops his own martial arts style
called the way of the spider the sad
thing is that he uses it twice in Spider
Island and I don't think we ever see it
again that's the saddest thing about
this because he basically gets a spider
since back he's like well I don't really
need that anymore and that's it it kind
of sucks you know but the cool thing is
that you know with regards to this whole
training sequence he's really learning
from one of the greatest martial artists
and the entirety of the of the Marvel
Universe but what we do is we pick up
you know again this is really really
fast you pick up with a few days after
this training session I guess over the
course these training sessions with
spider-man leaving and we find out that
all of this is being watched by the new
Madame web Julia carpenter now the
concept of Madame web is interesting in
the realm of spider-man remember when
Dan Slott took over the title you know
everything really I guess the the role
of Sparta Ireland was kind of grabbing
all these different stories that were
leading up to it grabbing all these
things in the spider-man mythos and
saying here's what I want to keep here's
what I don't want to keep and Spider
Island served the purpose of just
getting rid of everything - Dan Slott
didn't want to keep you know getting rid
of all that so what we'll cross that
bridge when we get to Spider Island but
madam web was kind of like just holdover
from an earlier time and in spider-man
comics but madam web is tied
intrinsically into the web of life and
destiny or destiny in life whatever you
call it and that's where people seem to
get confused and in Marvel Comics in
Spider Man mythos that was a huge point
in spider-verse a lot of people were
thrown off by the wave of destiny in
life so let's let's talk about this for
a second because this is more important
amount of life madam web is just like an
Oracle all right you can just see the
future that's
all she can do it's cool whatever she's
applied to bison in Spider Island so um
the web of life and destiny is this
really cool thing because in Marvel
Comics every group every subgroup of
superheroes has its own kind of access
to the multiverse and it's not like
Marvel engineered it to be that way it's
not like in 1962 was fantastic for
whatever it was tomorrow you know that
the Stan Lee and Jack Kirby sat down and
said okay guys over the course of the
next 50 years we're going to lay out
multiversal access with these different
individual teams it just kind of
progressed that way it just kind of
turned out to be that way it's cool but
it turned out to be that way for example
the British superhero team Excalibur has
what's called the lighthouse and the
lighthouse is basically a portal more or
less I mean you know you go into it you
can access the Captain Britain Corps
that's what you know Brian Braddock does
he goes into the lighthouse he accesses
the omniversal omniversal development
court I think is what it's called
and a Captain Britain Corps this
multiversal group of Captain Britain's
from across the multiverse in the mutant
landscape you have what's called the
m'kraan crystal
if you imagine the multiverse to be a
hallway of doors each door going to a
different universe the m'kraan crystal
is that door each universe has its own
m'kraan crystal that's why if you were
to destroy the m'kraan crystal in any
given universe it would be tantamount to
blowing the door off the hinge in which
case all the energies of the multiverse
would just come pouring in and it would
lead to the destruction of that of that
universe itself and then eventually the
multiverse would just condensed in on
itself and the multiverse would be
destroyed so it creates kind of a weird
situation and in the realm of
traditional superheroes the Fantastic
Four the Avengers so on and so forth we
have the negative zone you know in all
the multiverse there's only one negative
Zone in any universe can access that the
Ultimate Universe can access it the main
Marvel Universe can access it they all
have access to the negative zone the
webbing of a web of life and destiny is
the exact same way the difference here
is that individuals who can tap into the
web of life and destiny whatever you
want to call it can see the future
and that's the huge difference when it
comes to all the other aspects of
multiversal access the lighthouse the
negative zone the m'kraan crystal those
individuals cannot see the future
the only exception that I think is maybe
the white phoenix of the crown jean grey
but even then I'm not going to swear to
that people who can who can basically
access that can can end up seeing this
future so it creates kind of a really
cool really cool situation with regards
to the Spider Man met those but yeah I
mean the whole expensive thing is really
just designed to serve the purpose of
saying hey guys here the
they're leading up to it you know madam
web is led to be looking into the future
and saying the spiders are coming you
know there's going to be this great big
huge conflict that's massive
you know calamity really you know of
catastrophic proportions in New York
which we know is going to be Spider
Island but if you guys are new here to
come this explain make sure you guys are
the sub button become part of the Rob
core if you guys enjoyed this video make
sure you drop a like and let me know
down in the comment section if that
explanation of the web of life and
destiny if that made sense if it didn't
I'm going to try to clear it up and make
a little more sense here but yeah guys
anyway we're going to go ahead and bring
this video to an end and it will catch
you all in it please
[Music]